[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants petit lou ye mirabel
ont été vraiment très très mignon
aujourd'hui ils sont allés se promener
avec leurs parents et ensuite ils ont
entièrement ranger leur chambre et vous
avez vous été bien sage
oui et bien gros jour vous a amené ainsi
qu'à nos deux petits copains une belle
surprise
vas-y gros source j ai pas facile d'une
seule main surprise
asseyez-vous pour tous les enfants tu
voter des sages fois ci une belle
histoire
ulysse va vous raconter l'histoire de pi
corps est la poule blanche attention la
séance commence
[Musique]
par une belle matinée d'été dame
picorettes la poule blanche picorer des
grains sous une rame et de petits pois
quand une cosse puis tomba sont là que
avec une telle force qu'elle cru que le
ciel allait tomber
alors elle pensa qu'elle devait aller
avertir le roi et elle s'en alla
sautillant sautillant sautillant et
rencontra chanteclair lecoq
où vas-tu comme ça picorettes la poule
blanche au chanteclerc dit elle
le ciel va tomber et je vais le dire au
roi
j'irai avec toi dit chanteclair et les
voilà sautillant sautillante sautillant
chanteclair et picorettes et ils
rencontrèrent clopinant le canard et le
canard le redis où allez vous comme ça
chantecler et picorettes il dira au
clopinant le ciel va tomber et nous
allons le dire au roi
j'irai avec vous dis clopinant il
dévoila sautillant sautillant sautillant
clopinant chanteclair et picorettes et
ils rencontrèrent dandinait tu dois
grise
tournez-vous comme sa copine au chaud
tout le corps et leur demanda loi au
dandy net
le ciel va tomber et nous allons le dire
au roi jurer avec vous dit andy net et
dévoila sautillant sautillant sautillant
dans dînette clopinant chanteclair et
picorettes et ils rencontrèrent compères
le renard et le renard le redis où allez
vous comme ça clopinant andine est
chantée claire et picorettes aux
compères le renard le ciel va tomber et
nous allons le dire au roi
venez avec moi dans dînette clopinant
santéclair et picorer
je vous montrerai le chemin qui va au
palais du roi mais ils répondirent au
nom qu'on perd le renard nous trouverons
bien le chemin tout seul et nous n'avons
pas besoin de vous ils arrivèrent au
palais du roi le roi se mit à rire de
leur naïveté mais il les remercia
beaucoup beaucoup et il ordonna à chacun
un très très beau cadeau
à cette échelle la remercie alors les
enfants ça vous a plu
[Musique]
eh bien elle évite au dos voilà patron
j'arrive
si vous ne niera bel au revoir un rappel
[Musique]
allons allons dépêche-toi au jour nous
allons être en retard alors onu et petit
ami rendormez vous vous faites de beaux
rêves et à demain
bonne nuit
[Musique]
où
on
bon